[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى هذه
الصور من كيف عاصمه اوكرانيا التي تعيش
على واقع المزيد من التطورات العسكريه
بعد يومين من ضربات روسيه واسعه
هذه صور من البرازيل البرازيل التي تعيش
حدادها على رحيل اسطوره كره القدم بلاي
وهذه الصور من امام المستشفى في مدينه
سوفاولو حيث توفى يوم امس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد اعلان
الدقه على مقررات التحكم العسكريه
الاوكراني
هجمات الروسيه بالمسيرات المتفجره
ولا من العام للنيتو يصف هزيمته اوكرانيا
داخل الاراضي الروسيه بالمشروعه ويقول ان
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هو اسرع طريق
لتحقيق السلام
روسيا والصين وحديث شراكه الاستراتيجيه من
جديد في قمه عبر تقنيه الفيديو
نظاما عالميا عاجلا
يؤكد ان الشراكه مع روسيا تهدف للتغلب على
التحديات المشتركه
عن قلقها من التقارب الصيني الروسي وتقول
ان حدثت بجين من تداعيات دعم موسكو في
حربها على اوكرانيا
وفي مساحه التوتر في بحر جنوب الصين حامله
طائرات صينيه تقترب من اكبر القواعد
الامريكيه في المحيط الهادئ البنتاجون
يعلن عن منى وشه بين مقاتله صينيه واخرى
امريكيه
وبجين تقول ان ارساله المتكرر سفونها و
طائراتها الحربيه الى المنطقه يهدد امن
الصين القومي
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرسميه كنا تبعنا معكم رحيل اسطوره كره
القدم العالميه والبرازيليه
وتحدثنا عن هذه الاسطوره التي الهمت
العالم كثيرا وكان لها فضل كبير على
اللعبه حيث تحقق كل خلال رحلته ثلاثه من
بطولات كاس العالم لبلاده يتفرد بذلك
تاريخ تاريخيا
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التاليه الذي يقول ما السر
الذي جعل منه اليه اسطوره وملهما للاجيال
جاءت الاجابات على النحو التاليه
53% قالوا ان السر انما يعود الى الحرفيه
الاستثنائيه في اللعب بينما اعز سبعه
واربعون بالمئذ ذلك الى التجربه الانسانيه
الصعبه والمتميزه التي مر بها
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في حصاد العام امريكيا معركه الانتخابات
النصفيه وما بعدها واسئله الطريق نحو
انتخابات الرئاسه
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا الجمعه
روسيا بعد اقل من 24 ساعه على عمليات قصف
مكثفه لمنشات الطاقه ياتي هذا بعد تاكيد
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استهدف مواقع لقياده
الاوكرانيه ومنشات للطاقه من جانبه قال
الامين العام الاطلسي
الاخيره على اهداف عسكريه في روسيا مشروعه
تماما مضيفا في تصريحات وردتها وكاله
الانباء الالمانيه ان الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا هو اسرع طريق لتحقيق السلام
فيما قال اندرياس مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده لن تقدم اي تنازلات بشان استقلال
ووحده اراضيها وسيادتها الكامله
تتجدد يوميات الحرب الاوكرانيه موشيكا على
اتمام عام بعد اقل من 24 ساعه من قصف روسي
مكثف استهدف منشات اوكرانيه للطاقه اعلنت
كييف الجمعه انها صدت هجوما بمسيرات
متفجره شانه الجانب الروسي كانت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت استهداف مواقع
للقياده الاوكرانيه ومنشات الطاقه تغذي
الصناعه عسكريه
وبحريه مكثفه على مواقع القياده
الاوكرانيه ومنشات الطاقه المعنيه بتشغيل
مؤسسات المجتمع الصناعي العسكري الاوكراني
ودمرت جميع الاهداف
احسن ناطق العسكري الروسي مئات القتل
الاوكرانيين وعشرات المواقع والاليات
المدره يتطاير شضل الحرب وراء الحدود
وتتواصل تداعيات سقوط الصاروخ الاوكراني
في بيلاروسيا ولا يستبعد قائد قوات
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات في وزاره
الدفاع البلاسيا ان يكون الحادث استفزازا
الاوكرانيا دون ان ينفي اطلاقه بشكل غير
مقصود
من جانبه ابدى قلقا شديدا وقال الناطق
باسمه ديمتري ديسكو ان القوات روسيا وبيلا
روسيا على اتصال وتنسيق دائمين بما يتيح
امكانيه التبادل السريع للمعلومات الاكثر
حساسيه واضاف بسكوف ان بيلاروسيا اتخذت
عددا من الاجراءات بهذا الشان اتجاه
الجانب الاوكراني المواقف الاكرانيه
وبعيدا عن خبر الصاروخ تواصل التاكيد في
ظل توافق يصفونه بالكامل مع واشنطن على
عدم تقديم اي تنازلات بشان استقلال اراضي
اوكرانيا وحدتها وسيادتها الكامله على كل
شبر بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم
لدينا توافق مع الجانب الامريكي في جميع
القضايا بنسبه 100% هم يتفهمون ما هي
نهايه الحرب وما هي الاهداف والتنازلات
التي لا يمكن تقديمها الجانب الامريكي
يداعم لنا ويؤمن بان انتصارنا هو انتصار
له ايضا
سياسي يضمن سيادته اوكرانيا جاء ايضا في
تصريحات لامين عام حلف الناتو يونس
ستورتنبرغ الذي اعتبر ان دعم كلاب عسكريا
هو الطريق الاسرع لتحقيق السلام مضيفا ان
الهجمات الاوكرانيه على اهداف عسكريه في
روسيا مشروعه تماما تصريحات تاتي بعد
ساعات من اعلان روسيا عن التصدي مجددا لما
وصفت باهداف مجهوله فوق قاعدته الجويه في
العنق الروسي والتي تستهدف وفق الجانب
الروسي للمره الثانيه خلال الثلاثه ايام
ويبقى ان التاييد الاطلسي لهجمات
الاوكرانيه عابره للحدود ياتي رغم التاكيد
الامريكيه على عدم تحديد ذلك حذرا من
تصعيد يفضي لمواجهه امريكيه روسيه مباشره
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف فهم في كيف تصريح
بان الضربات في العمق الروسي الضربات
الاوكرانيه هي مشروع تماما
انه
القصفات استراتيجيه تستخدم
لاطلاق
صواريخ ضد الاهداف المدنيه الاوكرانيه
فانا ذلك فهذه
الطائرات وهذه القاعده تعتبر هدف مشروع
لانها لان انا ود اللحمه ههه
في حرب كامله مواجهه روسيا وبالتالي اذا
اعتقد اي شخص بان الاعرابي الروسيه ينبغي
ان تستثنى من اي ضربات
توجهها اوكرانيا
فهم كبير مخطئون ولا ولا يحصون الحقيقه
ومن الواضح انه اوكرانيا غير مهتمه باطاله
هذه الحرب ولكن
لايقافها لابد ان نعود الى ما هو مهم
للجميع احترام القانون الدولي
الحرف هذه تشن على اراضينا ضد مواطنين
الاوكرانيين ولهذا السبب فان علينا ان
نفعل كل ما في يسعدنا لايقافها بكل وسائل
المتوفره لدينا كيف نفسر التحفظ الامريكي
على هذه الضربات في حين النيته لا يرى همم
لها من عدم مشروعيه
[موسيقى]
غير مفهوم المؤثر
وهذا السبب ان الجميع
اهميه
المحافظه على حفاظ الدولي كما اسس بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه يدعمون اوكرانيا
ليست جانب الاوكراني الذي بدا بهذه الحرب
سبسكرا له دعم كبير وهو غير كافي لحد الان
نعم اعتقد انه يمكن نقدم لنا المزيد من
المساعدات والدعم وهذا سيغير الوضع على
الارض على الجبل وسيخلق فرص مفاوضات سلميه
على اساس مبادئ القانون الدولي وليس على
علشان
يعتقدبعض
فهم ليس لهم اي حق في غزه
فانه ليس لديهم اي حق
اهتم ليه
استيلاء على اراضينا
السكان التي عليها الذين عليها عود اللي
احنا قد فقط من اجدادنا بلغ قاتل من اجل
مستقبل اوروبا والاستقرار العالم واوروبا
والامني السعاده
شكرا جزيلا لك
والان معنا من موسكو ديمتري بابيتش الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد باش
اشاره النيتو لمشروعيه ضربات اوكرانيا
داخل العمق الروسي
ما تاثيرها في المستقبل برايك
العاميه صرح مثل هذا التصريح غير المسؤول
الذي يقول فيه انهم الشرعيه مشروع استهداف
اهداف العسكريه حتى لو وضعنا جانبان
الجانب القانوني من هذه المشكله فاعتقد
انه من خطر جدا خطر جدا مهاجره
لدوله ذات قوه نوويه هذا لم يحصل عام 1945
واعتق سيكون خطرا جدا القيام بذلك الان
اما فما يتعلق بقضيه المشروعيه الشرعيه مع
الاسف الغرب دمر القانون الدولي منذ زمن
بعيد وبالتالي عندما يكون الان ان روسي
الاول بلد يهاجم بلد اخر مذهب 1945 او 89
هذا غير صحيح اطلاقا في حدود المانيا
سيارات وحدود اتشكرت يتغيرت
وحداتي غسلافيا
والصربيا تغيرت به العنف في التسعينيات
وكل ذلك جرى بموجب رغبات الدول الغربيه في
نهايه المطاف
وطبعا هناك العراق
عندما يقول غير ان روسيا انتهت القواعد
والقوانين والقانون الدولي فانا روسيه ليس
هو من يفعل ذلك ورد ذكرهم ان ان الصفقه في
بدايه التسعينيات كان ان نيته لن يستخدمه
اراضي همم الحلفاء اتحاد السعودي السابقين
الجمهوريات السابقه لا تستخدم ضد روسيا
هذا مكتوب في عده وثائق تبناها 990 و97
ولكن الغرب همم
يستهين ويستخدم كل هذه العود اذا من ناحيه
القانونيه
وما هو اهم من ذلك هو مخطئ من ناحيه
الحقائق فهودوا ان يذكركم بانهم منذ عام
1999 على الاقل الغرب هو الذي يستفز روسيا
كان يعمل الغرب ان روسيا لن ترد في روسيا
ولن ترد في اوكرانيا
فقد استجابت روسيا في روسيا واستجابت في
اوكرانيا والان يحاول انه يحاول بالقول
ماذا لو ضربنا بعض الاهداف في راضي
الروسيه على نجحنا روسيا لن تستطيع او ترد
على ذلك
فقط
على الجميع يكرر مره اخرى
ان هجوم على الدوله ذات قوه نوويه فكره
سيئه في جميع الاحوال باختصار سيد بابيتش
هل نحن الان امام طريق مسدود عسكريا لا
روسيا قادره
تنتصر ولا اوكرانيا ايضا قادره على النصر
[موسيقى]
طويله هذه الحرب حسب رايي تعلمنا منها
دروس كثيره تعلم الناس دروس منها
فقد شاهدنا ان الحروب في العراق وفي ليبيا
هذه ليست حبوب تقليديه بل هي حروف
استعماريه يمكن ان تنتصر فيها قوه
السياسيه
حرب عالميه ثانيه يشارك فيها الكثير من
الناس هو الكثير من التجديد والتعبئه ليس
فقط المحترفين والكثير تستخدم ليست
بالضروره معقد الاسلحه الغربيه المعقده بل
على نجاح الاسلحه السوفيتيه وروسيه هي
التي تستخدم اذا فجاه نرى انه في الحقيقه
ان الغرب غير مستعد للحرب الحديثه الحرب
الحديثه اوكرانيا وروسيا كلاهما استعدوا
لها اما كذلك وبالتالي يعتقل هذه الحرب
ستكون تاثيرات
للنيتو الحلقه
لن يخاطر روسيا
لانهم يصيرون
وتشويه لحد كبير الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وفي الاربعينيات والغرب
رهيبه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في اطار التقارب الصينيه الروسيه في زمن
حرب اوكرانيا اجر الرئيسان الذي بوتين
والصيني
قمه عبر الفيديو اكد خلالها تعزيز التعاون
العسكري بينهما والعمل على مواجهه ما سمي
بضغوط الغرب واستفزازته غير المسبوقه
وتوقع الرئيس بوتن زياره شيء لروسيا خلال
الربيع العام المقبل وكان الرئيسان عقد
لقاءات مباشره ثلاث مرات خلال العام
الجاري واجري عده اتصالات الهاتفيه لبحثه
عده قضايا ابرزها مواجهه عالما احاديث
قدره
يا اختي
تقارب في زمن حرب اوكرانيا بعد جفاء في
مرحله تاريخيه ما الحلف الروسي الصيني
المبني على مواجهه حلف الغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده يتعزز يخاطب كل منهما
الاخر بالصديق العزيز من الرئيسين الروسي
المرشحا للتطور كلما طالت الحرب في
اوكرانيا اكد بوتين على تعزيز التعاون
العسكري بين البلدين ومن اجل عالم متعدد
الاقصاب سيعملان
كده انا ينظر بنفس الطريقه لاسباب ومسار
ومنطق التحول مستمر في المشهد الجيو سياسي
العالمي وعلى الرغم من الضغوط الغربيه غير
المسبوقات تستمر الروسيه والصين في الدفاع
عن مواقفهما المبدايه
جدا واهدافه متعدده
علاقاتنا وهذا ما يعكس تطور معدل التبادل
التجاري الذي بلغ مستوى 100 مليار دولار
واقول بصراحه اننا نمر بتحديات مختلفه وفي
ظل ظروف الصعبه يجب ان نساعد بعضنا في
التغلب على هذه التحديات
القمه الافتراضيه لبحث واقع كله رهانات
غير مسبوقه سبقتها مواقف ولقاءات مباشره
فقبل ايام قليله اجره بيت وموسكو منورات
عسكريه في بحر الصين الشرقي زادت من قلق
وغضب واشنطن وحلفائها وتبقى الصين على
الراس قائمه الاسواق البديله للنفط والغاز
الروسيين لمواجهه العقوبات الغربيه
من الغاز عبر الخطوط الانابيب وسفن الغاز
الطبيعي المثال لكن مع تحسينات المخطط لها
ستصبح روسيا المورد الرئيسي للغاز للصين
في الربيع المقبل اخر لقاء بينهما كان في
سمرقند خلال القمه منظمه شنكاي في سبتمبر
الماضي وقبلها في بيجين في فبراير الماضي
وقع حينها شركه نستراتيج بلا حدود اسسها
انعدام الثقه المشترك بالغرب من اوكرانيا
الى تايوان مرورا بمنطقه اسيا الوسطى
ربيعو حلفي روسيا والصين كم سيتم
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه صوت ايست
في النرويج اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
هل من الدقيق الان ان نتحدث فعلا عن شراك
استراتيجيه بين روسيا والصين
سنوات في العام 2014
الولايات المتحده
اسقطت الحكومه في اوكرانيا
واتت بحكومه مضاده لروسيا وبعد ذلك
الصين
واعلنتين وروسيا استراتيجيه شراكه
استراتيجيه وهي مستمره طبعا عندما غزت
روسيا اوكرانيا في هذا العام بالطبع الغرب
فرض عقوباتاته وهذا ما زاد من زياده
التعاون الاستراتيجي فيما يتعلقوا
بالدفاعات بالتبادل في الدفع بالعملات
محليه وتبادل تكنولوجي وغير ذلك عندما
تتحدث ايضا موسكو وبجين في هذا اللقاء عن
نظام عالمي جديد اكثر عدلا
كيف لهما ان ان ان يسعى يا الى ذلك
وان يجدوا نظام اقتصاديا جديدا تكون فيه
البلدان لا تعتمد
الشكر لان الكل له اعتمد على المتحده فيما
يتعلق
والنقل والمواصلات والنظام الصافي فان
الوقت المتحده ستملي شروطها في كل شيء
هؤلاء يحاولون ايجاد
النظام يحول دون تدخل المتحده لتسقط
الحكومات وتغذوا وما الى ذلك ستدخل في
سياده البلدان الاخرى همم
روسي يحاولون ان يخففه من اعتماده
اقتصاديا على امريكا مما يجعل النظام
العالمي في
اكثر عضلا والولايات المتحده هيمانتها
تتراجع على العالم سيد جليندشن ستبقى معنا
لنعود اليك في الملف التالي وهو ايضا
مساحه تصعيد اخرى بين القوه الكبرى فقد
اعلنت طوكيو ان حامله طائرات صينيه اقتربت
من جزيره اجوان التي تضم اكبر وجودا
عسكريا امريكيه في المحيط الهادم هذا
الخبر ياتي في وقت دعت فيه بيجين واشنطن
الى الالتزام بسياسه الصين الواحده وعدم
التحريض تحريض تايوان على الاستقلال والى
الابتعاد عما وصفته بالاستفزاز
نينجا
فقط
صينيه ترفع مستوى التوتر فحامله الطائرات
التابعه للبحريه الصينيه ليومنج توجهت في
ناحيه الجنوبيه لليابان الى غرب جزيره
تيجوان حيث يقيم الجيش الامريكي اكبر مركز
لقوته في المحيط
اما بيجين فليتحركها ما يبررها تقول ان
نشاط السفن الامريكيه وطائرتها لاستطلاعيه
بالقرب من الصين تهديد لامنها القومي
الصيني العمل الاستفزازي والخطير للولايات
المتحده هو السبب الجدري للقضايا البحريه
نحث الولايات المتحده على وقف هذه
الاستفزازات الخطيره والكافيه عن توجيه
الى الصين
على قاعده هذه بتلك ترد الصين اذا ربما
يفسر ذلك المناوره غير الامنه حسب وصف
الجيش الامريكي التي نفذتها طائره عسكريه
صينيه قرب طائره اخرى امريكيه في الحادي
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري في بحر جنوب
الصين قال الجيش الامريكي ان قائد الطائره
الامريكيه الطره الى المناوره لتفادي
الاصطدام بالطائره الصينيه التي حلقت على
بعد سته امتار فقط كل هذه التطورات في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ ليست الا تجليات
لتفاعلات ازمه جزيره تايوان فقد وافقت
الخارجيه الامريكيه هذا الاسبوع على بيع
انظمه مضاده للدبابات
180 مليون دولار
بالنسبه الى واشنطن فان تايوان هي حجر
الزاويه في الدفاع عن مصالحها ومصالح
حلفائها في منطقه المحيط الهادئ
وترك الجزيره للصين سيسمح لبيجين ببسط
سيطرتها على اكثر الممرات المائيه اهميه
في اقصى الشرق وعلى حركه الامدادات ثم ان
الطيران الصينيه قادرا على توسيع نطاقه
الى 150 ميلا بحريه في حال ضم تايوان ما
يعني تهديدا مباشره للقواعد الامريكيه
مخافه حصول ذلك تعزز الولايات المتحده
دعمها لتايوان وهذا ما جعل الصين تدعوها
للالتزام بالسياسه الصين الواحده والكف عن
تحرير تايوان على الاستقلال
نعود اذا الى الدكتور العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه صوت ايس في النرويج اهلا وسهلا بك
من جديد سيد ددسن
هذا التوتر البحري والجوي بين الصين
واشنطن ما مدى خطورته الفعليه
اه والله
المتحده لديها استراتيجيه دفاعيه تقوم على
ساعه الهيمنه في العالم ولا تسمح بظهور
ايه تحدي لها لكن ماذا لك الصين تشكل
تحديدا
لها ولهذا تحاول امريكا كفحه الصين وتقليل
قوتها من خلال مهاجمه اقتصاد الصين وايضا
من ناحيه العسكريه تحاول احتواء الصيني
عسكريه
وايضا
تايوان
اساسيه في السياسيه
الامريكيه
والولايات المتحده تشعر بان الوقت ليس
لصالحها فلذلك هي تدفع باتجاه انفصاله
تايوان عن الصين وهذا امر خطير لانه ينهي
صدام صار 40 عاما سياسه الصين الواحده
لهذا السبب الصين ردت بقوه لان الوقت
المتحده اذا ما دفعت باتجاه انفصال تايوان
فان الصين ست تحاول استرداد تايوان بالقوه
العسكريه
والامور تؤشره الى هذا التصعيد والتصعيد
المستمر لان الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان
تتراجع عن المواقفها اذا اذا ترى ما يجري
الان نوع من التسخين الامريكي لانفصال
تايوان
هذه هي
الطريقه التي يحاولون بها احتواء
وتقويض
العدو
تماما كما كما حصل في اوكرانيا في 2014
عندما ارادت الراتب المتحده اضعاف روسيا
هي تحاول الان عن طريق مساله تايوان
اضعافه الصين لهذا السبب هذه المنطقه
اصبحت ميدان قتال مهم الوقت المتحده الذين
صعود الصين شكرا جزيلا لك
من انهوش
[موسيقى]
ضمن تغطياتنا لاهم الاحداث التي شهدها
العام الجاري شهدت الولايات المتحده خلال
العام الذي نودعه انتخابات النصفيه جاءت
نتيجتها خلافا للتوقع قبل ان يفقد
الديمقراطيون اغلبيتهم في الكونجرس اوسط
نزله برلمانيه بتوجيه تهاما لرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وبعد الكبار المساعدين في
خطوه غير مسبوقه في التاريخ الامريكي
[موسيقى]
نجح الديمقراطيون في دار موجه حمراء بعد
حمله انتخابيه مشحونه
وتوقعاته عزوزتها اوضاع اقتصاديه متعثره
ودروس تاريخيه
ترجح كفه الحزب المعارض
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب بينما عزز
الديمقراطيون اغلبيتهم في مجلس الشيوخ
بمقعد اضافيه
في احداث السادس من يناير وسط خشيه من
ردود فعل عنيفه من مؤيده
ترامب لكن على وزاره العدل تاخذ ذلك في
الحسبان وعليها محاسبته اذا كانت تعتقد
انه ارتكب جرمان
على صحه الدوريه ازدادت
علاقتهرا بسبب الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا
كما فرضت واشنطن عقوبات غير مسبوقه على
الاقتصاد الروسي من فرض حظر على والده
النفط والغاز الروسي الى عقوبه في حق
افراد ومؤسسات مصرفيه الى عقوبه حرم
الصناعه الاسلحه الروسيه من الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
وفي الوقت الذي وجد فيه اداء الرئيس بيدن
استحسانا داخليا في موضوع اوكرانيا واجه
اداءه انتقادا في باقي الملفات الدوليه
بالمفاوضات مع ايران في حين ان العلاقه مع
الصين ما تزال متوتره وتواصل كوريا
الشماليه تجاربها الصاروخيه
على المستوى الاقتصادي ظلت نسب البطاله
متدنيه وبدات اسعار الوقود بالتراجع لكنني
سبب تضخم ما زالت مرتفعتا
ويعتقد بعض الاقتصاديين ان رفع اسعار
الفائده لكبح جماحها قد تؤدي الى نتائج
غير محموده
العمل والسؤال كم من الوقت سيحتاجه
الاقتصاد من اجل التافه
في حين يرى اقتصاديون ان البنك الاحتياطيه
لا يملك بديلا عن رفع اسعار الفائده
للسيطره على خطر تضخم رغم كل هذه التحديات
تستقبل امريكا
بموسم انتخابين رئاسيه بدا مبكرا وهي
منقسمه على نفسها وفي ظل مؤسسات الدستوريه
لا تقل انقساما محمد العلمي الجزيره
معنى من واشنطن النائب الديمقراطيه السابق
عن ولايه فرجينيا ومن اريزونا تريند فرانس
النائب الجمهوريه السابق عن ولايه اريزونا
اهلا بهما نبدا بضيفنا من واشنطن
سنقسم الحديث للملفات الداخليه ثم الملفات
الخارجيه لو بدانا بالملفات الداخليه
الامريكيه ما الذي سيبقى من عام 2022
وسيفرد قوته في العام المقبل
ايمو تعمل ونوامر واسباني
ا
المتحده ستمر بحاله من التقاطع
تراجع في فرص العمل لا ادري كيف يمكن ان
نتفادى انخفاض اسعار المنازل وارتفاع
اسعار البضائع
وانخفاض القدره الشرائيه بسبب انخفاض فرص
العمل نواجه اوقات صعبه وربما يبقى
الكاسات حتى العام 2014
العالم اجمع الم واملوا ان لا يتم ذلك لكن
هذا من الاحتمالات الوارده اذا السيد
جمهور عندما تتحدث فقط عن الجانب
الاقتصادي معناه ان هذا هو الملف الاهم
على الاطلاق في العام المقبل
»
القدره العائلات على توفيره احتياجاتها
تحتياجات اطفالها منازلها وما الى ذلك هذه
القضيه الاكثر اهميه للجميع لكننا ايضا
نحتاج الى الامن وتحتاجها العائلات لان
تعيش في احياء امنه وان يرسل اولادهم الى
مدارس جيده وان تكون حكومهم كفوئه لا
تصرفوا في الانفاق واذا ما انفقت تنفق
المال على الضروريات وهذه هي الاولىويات
في نظري الجميع وكان الامر كذلك على مر
الاجيال ولا يتغير اعتقد ان القضايا
الثقافيه ليست في اهميه القضايا
الاقتصاديه وقضايا الامن هذه الاولويات
الاقتصاديه في في اريزونا كيف تتوقع ان
تعالج في المقبل
ميكروفون
اذن انا ساعيد السؤال في انتظار ان تتضح
الصوره والصوت بالنسبه للسيد فرانكس سؤالي
له كان ما اذا كانت هذه الملفات
الاقتصاديه ستعالج بطريقه ما في العام
المقبل
واضح تماما ان هناك اشكال مع السيد فرانكس
اذا اعود مره اخرى للسيد جيم مورن واواصل
معه الملف الداخلي ولكن هذه المره فيما
يتعلق بالجانب السياسي السيد جيمس همم ما
يثار الان عن الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وامكانيه
محاكمته واقصاء ربما من رغبته في الترشح
همم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله كيف
تنظر الى هذه المساله
ايفون
الديمقراطين مدينون بشكل كبير لدونالد
ترامب لانهم ما كانوا يستحقون نتائج طيبه
ابدا لو ان
ترامب لما
يؤيد بعض المرشحين
المشكوك بامرهم وايضا بعض كبار القضاه
الذين امتهنوا حقوق المراه اعتقد ان ذوب
ايضا
سياخذ الانتخابات مرشحا ضد دونالد ترامب
لانه يشعر انه يستطيع الانتصار عليه لكنني
لا اظن ان ترامب سيكون مرشحه جمهوريين لان
كثير من الجمهوريه الخاصه
المعتزلين منهم لا يرون في ذلك مصلحه خاصه
وان ترامب لم يدفع اي خلاص هذا امر مخزن
لان كثيرا من الامريكيين يدفعون الكثير من
مالهم لقاء همم
الضرائب
دونالد ترامب في رشح نفسه على اساس قدراته
الاقتصاديه ثم يثبت انه لا يدفع الضرائب
اذا ما كانت ترامب هو المرشح سيحقق
ديمقراطيون ان صيبه اما اذا كان
هو المرشح فانه سيكون مرشحا اقوى ضد
الديمقراطيه
قليلا الملفات الخارجيه بالنسبه
للساحه الامريكيه سيد مورن همم بين
اوكرانيا والعلاقه مع روسيا والعلاقه مع
الصين
لمن ستكون الاولويه في العام المقبل وسط
هذه التحديات المختلفه
ستكون
الدعم لي اوكرانيا واعتقد ان ال ال
الولايات المتحده ستستمر بقياده الناتو في
هذا المجال لان هذه القيم امريكيه
تتم المحافظه عليها لكن هناك صعوبات اخرى
خاصه على صعيد الملف النووي الايراني لا
اعتقد اتفاقا سيتم التوصل اليه كثيرون
المتحده يودونا رؤيه امريكا وهي تؤيد
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات لكن لا ادري كيف يفعل ذلك ايضا
اقوى واقسى الحكومات اليمنيه التعصبا
عنصريه في تاريخ اسرائيل هذا كله
صعب الامر الامريكي وخاصه
كده اليهود الامريكيين الذين هم اكثر
الابراليه
وتنورا من حكومه اسرائيل الحاليه لذا سنرى
تحديات ايضا السعوديه واضح
انها
لم تكون على قائمه الرئيس مازن لمن
سيحصلون على الهدايا بمناسبه اعياد
الميلاد بسبب استمرار التوتر معها طبعا
ايضا محمد بن سلمان اضافه الى محمد بن
زايد ايضا لان الامارات تساعد ليبيا
وتساعد سوريا ايضا والامارات
تعرض التوجهات الديمقراطيه اضافه السعوديه
لهذا السبب
ارى ان الولايات المتحده انه
ستدير ظهرها بعض القضايا المهمه في الشرق
الاوسط لان المتحده ستحتاج الى مده طويله
للتعافي من كارثه الحرف العراق والتي ما
كان ينبغي ان تتم هناك الكثير من الامور
في افريقيا
الانفجار السكاني والتزايد عدد السكان لا
ادري هل انه المتحده
ستتدخل بنفس الدرجه التي تتدخل بها الصين
روسيا لا ادري لكن في اسيا امريكا ستلعب
دورا محورين خاصه فيما يتعلقوا بعلاقه
مع تايوان لان امريكا ملتزمه بالدفاع عن
طريق ولكنها لا تريد خوض حرب مع الصين
بسببها اذا هناك الكثير من قضايا السياسه
الخارجيه الرئيس مازن في نظري اخطا
بالانسحابي من افغانستان بالطريقه التي
انسحب بها كان الامر يتطلب وتخطيطا افضل
مما اظهرتها المتحده لكن في النهايه يعتقد
انه حقق نتائج لا باس بها لكن حتى اليوم
امامه وتحديات كبيره للعام المقبل
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك سيد تم مرن النائب
الديمقراطيه السابق عن ولايه فرجينيا
ونعتذر بالنسبه للسيد تراند فرانكس النائب
الجمهوري السابق عن ولايه اريزونا الخلل
الفني لم يسبح
بالاستمرار معه وهذا طبعا ليس معناها اننا
اعطينا الاولويه للنائب الديمقراطيه على
النائب الجمهوريه اذا بعد حديثنا عن
المشهد الامريكيه هذا تفكيرا بما خلصت
اليه الانتخابات والنصفيات الاخيره
سيطر الجمهوريون على مجلس النواب 222
مقعدا بعد ان اكتسبوا تسعه مقاعد من
الديمقراطيين وتجاوز عتبه 218 مقعدا ليبلغ
عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب
احتفظت الديمقراطيون بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ عبر انتزاع ولايه بنسلفانيا من
الجمهوريين يبلغ عدد مقاعد الحزب
الديمقراطي في مجلس الشيوخ 49 الى جانب
مقعدين للمستقلين الذين يصورون عاده لصالح
الحزب الديمقراطي بينما يبلغ عدد المقاعد
الحزب الجمهوري 49 بعد خساره الحزب مقعد
ولايه بن سلفانيا
[موسيقى]
من الحفاظ على مقعده في مجلس الشيوخ عن
ولايه جورجيا بانتخابات لاعاده بالبدايه
التي شهد التنافس حادا مع المرشح الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
كشف اللواء ستيفن رودينا رئيس وباحثه
المراقبه التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي
ان الجبهه تقراي بدات في اجراءات
واستعدادات لنزع الاسلحه الثقيله
بعثه المراقبه الافريقيه في الاقليم التي
تاسست بموجب البند الحادي عشر من اتفاقيه
السلامه الموقعه بين الحكومه الاثيوبيه
على تنفيذ بنود ترتيبات البنود الامنيه
المتمثله في نزل اسلحه وانسحاب القوات من
خطوط التماس وعودتهم للسكنات العسكريه
اضافه الى تسريح الميليشيات واعاده دمجها
في المجتمع هذا وقد افاد شهوده ايام بان
جنودا ارتريين انسحبوا من الاقليم باتجاه
الحدود
اذا وقفت الحكومه تان الاثيوبيه والارتريه
ولشهور عدى من اندلاع الحرب في تقرايه
نفتا تدخل اريتريا في الحرب الى جانب
الحكومه الفيدراليه التي يقودها ابي احمد
ولكن بعد تفاقم الاوضاع في تجري جراء
الحرب الطاحنه اعترف الرئيس الارتري
السياسه فوركي بالتدخل في هذا النساء فما
اسباب هذا التدخل
دعمت اريتريا جبل تحرير في حرب عام 91
والتي شنتها الجبهه على حكومه الرئيس
الاثيوبيه الراحل من جسته الى المانيا
انتصرت الجبهه وسيطرت على اثيوبيا عمى
ثمانيه وتسعين انتهى التحالف بين ارتريا
واثيوبيا الجديده بقياده جبهه اذا اندلعت
حرب طاحنه لمده عامين تغير الوضع السياسي
في اثيوبيا واصيحت جبهه عن السلطه ووقع
الرئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه الجديد ابي احمد
اتفاق سلام من مع ريتريا عام 2018 لينه
لذلك عقدين من القتال في نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني 2020 شنت حكومه ابي احمد الحرب على
جبل تقراي التي سيطرت على اقليمي
وقفت اريتريا الى جانب اثيوبيا هذه المره
وارسلت قواتها الى الاقليم وانتهت الحرب
باعلان سيطره الحكومه المركزيه الاثيوبيه
على عاصمه الاقليم بعد سته اشهر من الحرب
اعترفت اثيوبيا بوجود قوات الارتريه تقاتل
الى جانب القوات الحكوميه الاثيوبيه و
وعدت بانسحابها
ما يحدث اليوم في تجراي انما هو نتاجا
اتفاق سلاما او برما في الثاني من تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر الماضي حيث وضع حدا لسنتين
من القتال في ثاني اكبر بلد في افريقيا من
حيث السكان في واحده من اكثر الصراعات
الدمويه في العالم نص الاتفاق على تنفيذ
برنامج عمليه
لنزع السلاح والتسريح واعاده الادماج
وعوده المؤسسات الفيدراليه
وكذلك اعاده فتح الطرق والاتصالات الى هذه
المنطقه المعزوله عن العالم منذ منتصف عام
2001 2020
وستكون هناك اليه مراقبه تابعه للاتحاد
الافريقي لضمان تنفيذي بنود الارتفاع
ينضم الينا من اوسلو شتل ترانسلفول استاذ
دراسات السلام والصراع والخبير في شؤون
القرن الافريقي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد ترامبول
هل يمكننا القول الان باننا امام
حل نهائي لموضوع تقرايه
حلا النهائيه لكنه خطوه مهمه الى الامام
لتطبيق اتفاقي السلام
وما تسال هناك
مشكله
وعلاقه لكن اعاده
الارتباطات بالاتصالات والربط في
الانستغرام
وتدفق المساعدات النسائيه بشكل تدريجي
وفتحه بعض طرق المواصلات هذا يعني بدايه
التطبيق الاتفاق وايضا على الاقل للوقت
الحالي يبدا ان هناك عمليه بناء وتعزيز
الثقه بين الطرف لانه هذا امر جيد طبعا
خروج القوات الارتريه من مناطق في اقليم
طيب بعد فتره طويله من نفي الوجود هناك هل
يساعد
بشكل سوء
مساعد
فنحن تلقينا انباء في الايام القليله
الماضيه تفيد بانسحاب القوات العطريه من
بعض المدن في شمال ارتيريا وهذا امر مهم
وايجابي لكن ايضا ما زال هناك قوات في
مناطق اخرى الى اي مدى انسحبت هذه القوات
ليس ذلك معروفا هل بقيت منها
وحدات داخل الاراضيك لا ادري لكن المهم
لهذا القوات ان تنصحب بشكل كامل
لضمان سلامه السكان المدنيين التي تقرا
اليه المراقبه التي اقرها الاتحاد
الافريقي
لاتفاق نوفمبر الماضي
هل تراها
قابله للنجاح
المراقبه التابع لاتحاد الاوروبي تم للتو
تاسيسه هو بدا منذ يوم امس ممارسه مهامه
[موسيقى]
لكنه ما زال فريقا صغيرا ينقصه العدد
والعده وهم بحاجه الى تعزيز قواتهم
واضافه القوات اليهم ومهامهم صعبه
فقط قيام عشره اشخاص بمراقبه منطقه برمتها
شبه مستحيل هم بحاجه الى زياده العدد
وعليهم ان يستفيدوا من مساهمات اخرى وان
تكون هناك ضمانات
امنيه تجاه القوات الارضيه
والقوات التي ما تزال تحتل
غربتك
كل هذا القضايا العالقه هل تعتقد من بين
القضايا العالقه ايضا يجب اعطاء ضمانات
لعناصر جبهه الذين سيرقون السلاح ويسمحون
بعوده المؤسسات الفيدراليه الى الاقليم
فيسبوك ايمان
تشترط ان منظمه او جبهه التحرير
يجب ان حذف اسمها من قائمه الارهاب هذا لم
يتم بعد ان يرفع اسمها من قائمه الارهاب
وايضا اعطاء بعض الظمانات لافرادها
ولقادتها ايضا لتفادي ملاحقتهم
ايضا هناك كان بيتعلق بالمساءله والمحاسبه
اللي هي الفضائح التي تمت ليس في استغلال
فحسب في اثيوبيا ايضا طبعا كيف سيتم
التعامل مع هذه المحاسبه واي وفقا لاي
اليات هذا ليس واضحا طبعا بالنسبه
لقوات جبهه التحريري تقراي هل ستمنه
محاسبتهم ايضا على ما ينسب اليهم من فضائح
لا ندري كل هذه قضيه وقضيه المحاسبه
برمتها ربما هي القضيه الاكثر حساسيه
التي ستراها في المستقبل
اثيوبيه والارتريه
السيد
كاجوتيل ترامبول استاذ دراسات السلام
والصراع والخبير في شؤون القرن الافريقي
شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من اوسلو
[موسيقى]
هكذا ودع اطفال سوريون خيامهم للانتقال
نحو بيوت حقيقيه
الصور تتحدث عن نفسها بوضوح ولا تستدعي
المزيد من الكلام عن معاناه اللاجئين
السوريين وغيرهم في هذا العالم خاصه وقد
تبعنا لقطات كثيره لاطفال يتحدثون عن
البرد وما يعانون من برد وشوعه نهايه
الحصاد هذه الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]